Abraham follows me on Twitter Dave I'm
on baby step three which means he's out
of debt and doing his emergency fund and
my grandpa just passed away I'm sorry
should I pull from the emergency fund to
go to the funeral if you don't have any
other money yes I would say attending
your grandpa's funeral is an emergency
if you don't have the money to do it
otherwise definitely that's exactly what
it's for and I'm sorry you're facing
this financially when you have an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses you're sitting there with ten
fifteen twenty twenty-five thousand
dollars whatever it is three to six
months of expenses say twenty thousand
bucks sitting there in cash financially
what happens is it turns having an
emergency fund and being out of debt
except your house baby steps one through
three turns an emergency into an
inconvenience it used to be when we were
broke that when the car broke
we had drama financial drama because we
ended up money to fix the car and card
drama because we had a broken car
transmission goes out the water heater
blows the water pump goes out shreds a
belt whatever it is you know pay the tow
bill maybe maybe you've got them you
know and then you got paid for repair
bill and whatever it is you're facing a
mess then financially you got no money
and you got a broken car so it just
doubles or triples the drama but when
the car breaks and you have an emergency
fund you know what you do fix the car
yawn no biggie
not a problem heating there
goes out you have an emergency fine fix
the heat in their worst case replace the
heat in there here's what's interesting
when you have high emotion around an
event it's one of the things you can do
to activate memory if you want to
remember something tie something
emotional to it something very powerful
to it emotionally being broke and highly
stressed is very powerful emotionally I
remember when we were going through the
bankruptcy and I was a broke I mean
really broke and the air conditioner
goes out on our home we have a brand new
baby a toddler my wife is already angry
make her hot and angry he's not good
with two screaming babies that are hot
and angry super not good and I got a guy
at the church that knows how to sort of
work on these things to come out as a
favor and we found a used compressor
that he put on that thing and got that
stupid air conditioner working again and
it was 318 dollars that was almost 30
years ago and I remember precisely the
amount of money it took to fix it memory
is activated by stress fast-forward two
houses later
a decade later plus probably about a
decade later probably 20 years ago the
heating and air system went out on the
home we had purchased by then we've got
three kids we're doing pretty well a
financial piece had come out the book
and we were making some money off of
that
had a good emergency fund and I had to
put a heating and air unit on the side
of the house I can tell you it cost a
little more than three thousand dollars
but I honest I just don't remember
exactly what the bill was
might have been 30 200 might have been
3800 might have been a little over 4,000
but I know it was north of 3000 but I
know the other one was 318 dollars there
was no stress associated with that no
freakout associated with that no drama
associated with that and so it didn't
activate my memory the same way you have
a deep memory on things that mean
something deeply to you or that are
associated with high emotion of some
kind stress is one of the emotions and
there was just no problem I just yawned
wrote a check put a heat and air unit on
the house it was not a problem it turns
a crisis into an inconvenience and the
weird thing is not only do you have
fewer emergencies when you're not broke
but when you do have them you don't even
hardly emotionally recognize that
they're there to the point it's hard to
call them an emergency because emergency
sounds like sirens going off and it's an
emergency you know it's hard to call it
an emergency when you're just gone and
write a check and buy a $30,000 heating
and air system or a 3500 eating an air
system or whatever right it doesn't feel
like sirens going off so it doesn't feel
like you have an emergencies but you
don't have as many emergencies and
there's several reasons for that one is
your budget has more margin in it
because you're not broke and you're
picking up little things that used to be
emergencies but you're picking them up
as budget items the second thing is when
you're not broke you do proper
preventive maintenance on things like
cars and eating their systems some stuff
doesn't break as much plus as you not
broken more you buy better heating and
air systems and better cars so they
don't break as much and so you do have
fewer emergencies because you're dealing
a better quality stuff in the number of
times I've had a breakdown
on the side of the road in the past 20
years is zero prior to that I mean
Sharon and I are on our third date I'm
driving a Monte Carlo and college I had
a dollar 16 in my checking account right
and I knew how to turn a wrench on
that car cuz I had to keep the stupid
thing running right I'm in college I'm
so broke I can't pay attention we're on
our third date I'm explaining to her how
someday I'm gonna be a millionaire I got
a buck sixteen literally in my checking
account a dollar sixteen was the balance
and the checking account someday I'm
gonna be a millionaire I'm telling her
and about that time we went across a
railroad track of the muffler fell off
my car this is how it works I mean when
you're broke your life looks like a
country song you know everything that
can go wrong will and so that's the
advantage of the emergency fund
sometimes we don't stop and say hey
grandma's rainy day fund that god only
knows fun we don't stop and say the
importance of that as a foundational
element in your financial plan to allow
you to build wealth because until you
stop giving your money to repair man all
the time it's difficult to build wealth
and that comes with the quality
purchases of better items you're
upgrading in some things
it comes with margin in your budgets so
you're covering these things without
hitting the emergency fund certainly
without hitting the investment accounts
and it comes from wow it's just like
when you're broke you just it's hard to
have good luck and when you're not broke
you seem to have more good luck it's not
really luck but you see what I'm talking
about life variables in your life change
and even when something does come at you
I did blow a tire the other day on the
interstate hit a pothole I haven't done
that a long long time but I've got these
low profile tires on one of these cars
when these fast cars and it they don't
take a bump real quick I hit a pothole
the size of a crater and blew a tire off
of it you know what I can't tell you
what that tire cost I just you know I
actually I got in another car and went
on to the airport my son came and helped
me get the car you know my guys helped
me get the car off the road and got a
tire put on it or even remember buddy I
remember those retread y'all are about
retreads or you got tires that had new
treads put on
in college I used to buy retreads or
even know if they make those anymore
that was the ultimate in poor for me
buying retread tires man see you see the
difference an emergency fund turns a
crisis into an inconvenience an
emergency fund tons a crisis into an
inconvenience it's worth getting one
[Music]